je reçois Bernard Vasseur bonsoir
directeur de la maison Elsa Triolet
Aragon à Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes ici car
votre établissement dans lequel le
couple Elsa Triolet Louis Aragon a
résidé pendant de nombreuses années est
actuellement menacé par une diminution
des aides de l'État par une hausse de
loyer aussi réclamée à votre association
qui gère l'établissement une hausse de
48,6% cela ferait un loyer global pour
l'année de de 30000 euros pour 2013
c'est bien ça et ça vous ne pouvez pas
l'absorber donc non non avant de mourir
Aragon à donner cette maison à la France
donc le propriétaire aujourd'hui c'est
l'état mais c'est une association
présidée par Madame Edmonde Charles roux
grand écrivain qui est qui s'occupe de
faire vivre le lieu d'y accueillir le
public d'y rencontrer des scolaires bon
et nous le faisons devant de plus en
plus de visiteurs et de plus en plus de
scolaires plus de 20 000 personnes en
2012 et 7000 scolaires
en 2012 aussi alors que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui c'est très simple je suis
dans l'angoisse parce que on me retire
30 000 euros et que je ne sais pas
comment je vais payer les salaires des 7
personnes qui travaillent dans
l'association
de des aides de l'État on peut peut-être
aussi expliquer pourquoi vous payer un
loyer parce que c'est une maison qui a
été légale l'État au début auparavant
avant 2002 vous ne payez pas de loyer en
effet et ça a changé en 2002 oui
absolument c'est une bonne question que
vous posez vous voyez
un journaliste faisait remarquer puisque
Aragon et Elsa Triolet sont enterrés
dans cette maison que
c'est le cimetière le plus cher d'Europe
et peut-être même du monde pour
plaisanter naturellement et bien en
effet c'est une bonne question pourquoi
nous impose-t-on un loyer on vous a
donné une explication
chacune en nous si on nous a dit voilà
il y a une nouvelle loi effectivement
moi je suis directeur de la maison
depuis
2001 quand je suis arrivé on ne payait
pas de loyer et puis en 2002 on nous a
dit voilà la loi a changé il faut à tout
prix
désormais que vos rapports avec l'État
entre l'association et l'État soient
finalisée dans une convention qui
inclura un loyer mais on nous a aussitôt
dit ne soyez pas inquiets parce que ce
loyer on va vous allez le payer à l'état
mais l'État va vous augmenter d'autant
la subvention
pour vous c'est une opération blanche
aujourd'hui sauf qu'aujourd'hui
l'augmentation l'augmentation que même
le mystère de la culture nous dit on
n'arrive plus à suivre donc on ne vous
on ne vous compensera pas la la
l'augmentation du loyer l'augmentation
du loyer qui était alors l'augmentation
du loyer elle elle dépend du ministère
de l'économie et des finances et d'un
service qui s'appelle France Domaine qui
gère les biens de l'État ce service en
2011 nous a demandé 18000 euros et voyez
en 2002 c'était 11000 le rythme de
progression est quand même énorme mais
quand même élevé et en 2011 il était à
18000 et en 2012 28000 c'est là où vous
avez raison de dire 48% de
d'augmentation et en 2013 on nous dit ça
sera près de 30 000 c'est-à-dire soit
encore une augmentation de 2000 euros
alors si vous faites les comptes le
ministère de la culture dans sa
subvention la diminue pour la première
fois de 6% c'est-à-dire que ça fait
moins 10000 euros et de l'autre côté on
nous prend plus 22000 euros sur deux
années 2012 et dans le constat des
difficultés que vous pouvez rencontrer
vous nous dites ne pas avoir eu
d'explication sur ces différentes paires
de subventions hausse de loyer lorsqu'on
lit dans la presse c'est pour dire
par exemple vous avez demandé à la
ministre Filippetti des explications
madame Edmond de Charleroi qui est une
grande dame des lettres qui est la
présidente de l'Académie Goncourt qui
est une grande romancière et qui se
trouvait être notre présidente très
active de l'association a écrit à la
ministre au mois de mars nous avons
toujours pas de réponse il y a pas très
longtemps dans les locaux
cette occasion
avec elle à ce moment-là
c'était formidable c'était le bonheur
elle est venue elle nous a expliqué
qu'Aragon était très important pour elle
dans sa vie personnelle qu'il avait joué
un grand rôle très bien elle a dit que
notre association était formidable parce
que on avait une conception tout à fait
dynamique et vivante de la du patrimoine
qu'on le faisait vivre qu'on racontait
on a eu on a eu que des compliments donc
qui nous ont enchantés sur le coup et
c'est on est on a reçu le label maison
des illustres qui a été créé par le
ministère de la Culture et c'est nous
qui l'avons reçu c'est en 2011 et vous
étiez le premier effectivement à
l'obtenir et donc vous voyez on comprend
pas pourquoi aujourd'hui on s'acharne à
me noircir mais à me blanchir mes nuits
et plutôt pardon parce que je ne dors
pas parce que je me dis je suis dans
l'angoisse de me dire mais comment
moi je suis obligé de mettre à la porte
cette personne voilà c'est dramatique
l'ensemble des salariés que vous avez
actuellement si jamais il n'y a pas de
changement je ne sais pas comment les
payer au mois de décembre si je n'ai pas
ces 30000 euros voilà c'est très simple
alors vous comprenez ma langue mon
angoisse vous comprenez vous avez
peut-être deviné ma colère mais vous
devinez surtout que moi ce que je
voudrais c'est une réponse positive nous
avons écrit au ministère de la Culture
pas de réponse alors depuis peu depuis
de la presse là depuis qu'il y a eu des
échos dans la presse et je vous remercie
de m'inviter ce soir j'ai des coups de
téléphone
mais après on me dit qu'on n'est pas
sensible à la pression médiatique mais
enfin vous voyez quand même bon donc je
m'en réjouis je ne tiens pas à faire du
bruit pour le plaisir de faire du bruit
d'explication sur ces baisses de
subventions est-ce qu'en tout cas vous
vous avez le sentiment de remplir vos
missions vous parlez tout à l'heure de
faire vivre ce patrimoine de quelle
manière vous faites vivre la mémoire de
ses écrivains
on l'a fait vivre d'abord parce que
leur maison Aragon a donné sa maison à
la France on trouve qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement français le traite bien mal
la mémoire de ces deux écrivains
puisqu'il consacre de moins en moins
d'argent à la à soutenir l'association
qui fait vivre la maison mais
l'association elle de son côté elle fait
beaucoup d'abord parce qu'elle cherche
ses propres ressources elle n'est pas
uniquement dans la position d'une
quêteuse envers l'État non non elle a
ses propres ressources en 1998 la
subvention de l'État représentait à peu
près 95% de notre budget aujourd'hui il
en représente cette subvention pardon en
représente moins de 30%. c'est à dire
que la maison a trouvé d'autres
ressources des ressources qui que lui
procure son activité des ressources
qu'elle a inventées par exemple des
ateliers scolaires par exemple des
partenariats avec des villes avec des
collectivités avec des comités
d'entreprises par exemple aussi du
mécénat privé donc voyez nous faisons
tout pour ne pas rester dans un face à
face avec l'État sauf que nous
constatons quand même que l'État qui est
le propriétaire des lieux et évidemment
notre plus gros
souscripteur l'État lui fait de moins en
moins alors que nous avons le sentiment
et il le dit lui-même la ministre vous
l'avez rappelé elle-même alors que nous
avons le sentiment nous l'association du
moment donné de plus en plus voilà
pourquoi ça nous paraît un peu
léger un peu
inacceptable et bien on a bien entendu
votre colère ce soir sur ce plateau
Merci à VOUS directeur de la maison
à Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines et cette
colère qui s'explique par cette
diminution des subventions et cette
hausse du loyer et vous nous l'avez dit
vous risquez donc d'avoir licencier vos
sept salariés pour pouvoir vous
acquitter de ces différentes
augmentations de loyer à payer merci